where he's we're a bit of a hit of time
and he's
consented to do that so chris if you'd
like to come forward
and just share your thoughts with
council that would be um much
appreciated thank you
you're worried about this declare that
uh chris and my cousins
big partner declare that chris and i are
cousins right thank you thank you
i won't hold that again
okay um look welcome along chris and
today is an opportunity to
expand uh or add to the submission that
you've made
and a chance for you to make it clear in
council's minds
what your thoughts are there's 10
minutes to
to do that and then at the end of that
time
if there's any questions that counselors
might have about
the things you've said and want some
more information then there'll be
questions from council
so today is not about debating an issue
today is about getting as much
information as possible about an issue
so that councillors can make an informed
decision
uh when the time comes which is next
week so the floor's open to you chris
and there you go oh well i'm not just
speaking on my
on my own behalf i've got a lot of
friends
um other people in the community and
they've all voiced a lot of concerns to
me
and and one of the main ones is the um
the rate increases that the council keep
continually putting on to people
most people when they have a house they
have a budget
that's income they got coming in and
then they do what they can
with the income that they've got this
council seems to have this wish list
that they write this big list
and then they make the
ratepayers cop up enough money to cover
up your dream list
now i know there's a lot of things that
do need doing um
don't get me wrong but the way i see it
is when you've got major capital
expenditure
if it's not going to be covered by the
funding for depreciation it needs to be
put on the long-term loans
so the ratepayers today aren't carrying
the big burden i mean the ratepayers
that are coming in 30 years time
they're going to get gifted you know
all everything all the infrastructure is
going to be there and we're paying for
it now so
every if we've got user pays it needs to
be everybody needs to be paying
not just us today but people 40 years
down the track need to be paying for it
as well so
loans like that need to be long term for
some of the big expenditure things that
need doing like the
sewerage um and the sewage pipes and the
water
um ratepayers are just not an endless
bit of money you know like
our rates are going up 220 this year
i mean i can find it because i'm working
but it's still a struggle but the thing
is it keeps going up and up and if it
goes up like that
you're looking at another two thousand
dollars for the next ten years that our
rates are going to go up
which is going to make our rates four
and a half thousand almost double them
in the next 10 years
you know that's unrealistic you know
the council were actually supposed to be
air servants it's like we're servants of
the council you know the council will
just sit there and say right we want
this you know
or or whatever and that's the way people
out in the community say it a lot of
people
lethargic they'll moan and they moan and
they moan but they won't get up and do
anything and that's why i'm here because
i i'm not just a moaner i actually like
to stand up
um the council should be looking at ways
to save money
not just saying right we need to do this
and we need to do that
you know if i've got a household budget
and i'm running low on money
i try to find ways to trim the money you
know and i don't see a lot of that going
on here
i've had a lot of people moan to me
about the gardens and the amount of work
that goes into the gardens and the labor
force
you know the the council i see is
becoming a snowball it's just getting
bigger and bigger
um you know i just seen in the paper on
saturday
four new acts you know four job
applications
um an events coordinator well
yes we need events and gore to attract
people to gore
but the people who run these events it
shouldn't be the rate payers that are
paying for this
you know um and the other one i had
um was with the
um the new milk company that the council
push for us to get to to get here now i
well and good but i don't see many
benefits that the ratepayers
have actually got from that um they
might have contributed to the sewage
scheme so that they could actually put
the water in
but what's going to happen when the
sewer scheme when we update it and and
make it bigger and better so that it's
compliant
if they supply 30 of the intake into
that then they should be cut
coughing up 30 of the cost of it
um the council would sit on their hands
when when they paid the money for the
scheme
to to enlarge it and that council should
have got on board then and started the
um the process that they're doing now of
fixing this
um sewer scheme when they had that extra
money from the company
to help okay
um the other thing i have a problem with
is water
the um we're still pumping
water out of the river for for the town
town supply um they say they haven't
been pumping that much for the last two
years but we've had actually
last two summers have been wet summers
and we're still pumping water out of the
river so
um i know a lot of other people were
moaning to me about it but
the fact the council could find water to
supply to a foreign company to bring
them to gore
when we were having water restrictions
is just a bit on the nose
oh the other thing was that the council
when when they make the
um your budget and it comes up with a
thing if it goes to an auditor
the auditor doesn't should not have any
right and
as to say you need to up your rates
another one percent or two percent to
cover this or to cover that
they are there to make sure there's no
fraud going on and that the books
are accurate not to advise ourselves
on the other thing was i think the
council should be funding
concentrating more on some of their core
activities
um you know like a sewage footpaths
and gutters i mean i've got a block
drain
outside my work and i've rung up twice
it's been like that for a year
they fixed their footpath they put
asheville into the gutter
twice i've rung up the council and twice
they've sent us
street sweep around well you're not
going to sweep ash belt that's
set hard in a gutter and i've said to
the last time but nobody seems
to respond that well to complaints um
you know my gutter down down wiggins
street it's all broken up the concrete's
all
broken i have to spray it with gra you
know to get rid of the grass out of it
um things like that should be coming
for us before other things and and the
way i say before
the council should set a budget
um or you know with what they've got
with the money they got
not increase the rates just to um
to do everything that's on the book
i think that's all i had for the moment
all right the other thing was the roads
roads are for cars there's no need for
flower planters and stuff like that to
be sitting on on our roads
hard enough getting around anyway
without all that
that's all i got to say thanks thanks
chris
thanks for your thoughts and you
expressed them well
um just a question i have around
rates you said you had a two hundred and
twenty dollar increase
this last period what's what sort of
rates do you pay
well two and a half thousand the same as
most people but if eight and a half
percent
of that if you wear your mass it's 220
and each time then it's the five percent
increase because it's compounding so you
put
five percent next year it's on top of
the eight and a half percent
this year so it compounds yeah okay i
was just asking the full quantum of what
you pay in race
okay okay councillors um
open for any questions that you may have
in terms of clarification
so that you can make some decisions uh
when the time is
time comes so nobody's got any questions
at all
at this point okay look thank you chris
thanks for taking the time to be here um
and
i don't think there's any doubt in the
counselor's minds what your thoughts are
and and we've got a job before us to to
go through
not just the submissions but also the
full plan and
and consider whether that is fit for
purpose or it does need to have any
changes so
what you've said today will add to that
discussion so thank you thank you
okay right i think we might be on to our
last
and adam newton so adam's in the room so
if you'd like to come forward
adam um so this uh this proceeding is
being live streamed
so that's why the microphone is there
um so you've got 10 minutes and
at eight minutes there's a bell and then
there's a
another couple of minutes after that and
at that point in time
uh councillors if they have any
questions for clarification
will will ask those so this is not about
debating an issue at this point in time
it's about councillors
making sure that they've got all the
information they need
to make the right decision when the time
comes so perfect
the floor is yours thank you tracy uh
your worship the mere elected
councillors
council staff firstly thank you for the
opportunity to be able to speak
regarding the proposed long-term plan
my thoughts around certain projects that
the council have proposed or gone
through with in the past are probably
quite well documented
in this office the reasoning i would
suggest like most ratepayers
i'm frustrated i feel that the council
forever have been chasing their tales
and their approach to certain issues
very much a reactive rather than
proactive mindset with the cliche
proverbial whale in hindsight she was a
bit of a band-aid fix
an example of that i just like council
building looks lovely
beautiful building credit to the guys
that have done it
and then obviously with the expense of
the library as well
um we're four million
proposal there and six for this
i almost thought you probably got to go
probably got a pretty
well-rounded fit for purpose building
for 10 grand if you have
looked at it as a whole project you
thought it probably would have went a
bit further
um regarding the long-term plan
in three waters uh i do see the merit of
separating the rain water from sewerage
system
my thoughts to the council would be can
the present system handle the extra
load of stormwater given that the object
is to get the
stormwater that's going to the surge
into the stormwater drains
presently given surface flooding that
happens on a substantial downpour as a
justice
would probably not be the case
[Music]
would another option for obviously
segregating the stormwater to the sewage
be allow property
owners to fund by way themselves are
soakage put
on their own property it's therefore not
inundating the stormwater
um given that with your proposal with
what you're doing at elizabeth street
that's what's going to happen anyway
just going back into the ground
regarding the rural fund i'm indifferent
to
what gets used to the money i don't know
too much about the rural fund and how it
come about
but my obviously any depth servicing or
lowering
has got to be the smartest use of the
money unless there's opportunity for the
council to invest in something that
gives greater return than the interests
on the loans that are accruing
the other thing and probably the most
important thing i think for myself
personally
um is hasn't really been mentioned too
much in the long term plan is the growth
of the town um given i buy and develop
property and intend to do so for a long
period of time this is probably the most
interest
to me um at the moment there's sorely a
lack of both residential
land available and commercial land
available in gore
there's nothing really that caters to
that in the long-term plan and i think
that
that probably needs to be given some
serious thought
um the way i see it as a council you can
pay down debt two ways
one is the current norm of increasing
rates year on year
secondly is obviously increasing the
rating units available to you
which by way of more properties
so yeah just of counsellors and
counselors to
look 10 years into the future or not to
look 10 years into the future but maybe
20 or 30.
going forward thank you very much great
thanks adam i think you've made it
pretty clear what your thoughts are
and um you might be surprised that
sometimes we actually do agree on a few
things
um and it's really good to hear it in a
clear and
concise and respectful manner
okay open for discussion uh for uh
questions from councillors
that um you may need to make sure that
you've got clarification of what adam is
suggesting in um in relation to the
long-term plan
council governor yes good good
submission adam um just
one question has been a developer where
would you like to see gore's
develop out too and some suggestion of
ideas
um yeah thank you
uh i think we we should be focusing on
going up rather than out
um you look at say auckland
um and the mass sprawl that that's
become now
uh we've got the opportunity like
there's a lot of people
uh just bought a property late last year
doc sampson's place on canning street
and had a sign out the front while i was
doing it up and i had
in a space of that sign going up five
people ring me going oh you're going to
do anything with the land
sections and obviously close to town for
aging population are in demand
and you know there's guys out there now
um obviously fred springer um
just down counting streets taking away
house and put two wee
town houses in which is which is smart
but you only get two in there
i feel that if we are a bit more
intensive
but i don't know if cause ready for that
but obviously intensification
and going up so we still can have
elderly close to town close to services
library council
shopping rather than going out i don't
know if going out's the
answer
do you have any thoughts about
industrial expansion adam
um yep yeah
relocation of the soccer grounds would
be a good one
um they're sort of connected to central
or
south yep okay so
am i right in hearing what you're saying
that your expansion is within the
existing boundaries
as opposed to expanding the boundaries
you obviously got the growth to go
beyond the boundaries at present
um obviously you had the the document i
think was a year 18 months ago about the
where should google go um asking for
feedback
um and or sort of the irony thing i
thought that maybe the council should
have been ahead of the game with that
rather than
asking for ideas is like there's a lot
of clever people sitting around this
table
and in this building that that should
have been
um a priority to have
rather than put it out to the public
watch who should we make wealthy because
who's got the
land where we want to go i guess just to
elaborate a little bit on that
um yeah there are a lot of ideas within
this room and within this
building um but democracy being what it
is then
it's pretty important that the community
understand and ever say as well
i respect that okay um any other
questions
for adam at all if not look thank you
for the time you're taking to be here
today um thank you for the interest you
have
and uh we'll take all those points uh on
board as we
consider and deliberate this time next
week on what the plan looks like thank
you thank you very much
okay councillors look i think that
brings us to the end we've had
a number pull out um
and one that hasn't uh hasn't arrived so
i think
and he was due to be here at 3 20. so i
guess we can take it that
that he's not going to be coming so um
have counselors got any questions about
process from here
either of myself or the chief executive
um
before we close the meeting council
mcfarland
um just in regard to the the actual 153
submissions do we get a breakdown on the
um
on how that yeah
so now um the chief executive one of his
roles is to put together a response to
each of the submissions
for us to to consider and either
accept or change um but steve do you
want to make any comment
on that now yeah thank you
so there will be a report from me on
the submissions received
and we are attacking it in two and two
tranches so we're
um first my report will focus on those
that have
made submissions uh that
were in a written form and departed
somewhat from the
standard online template
and then i'll also include in that
some of the points raised by those who
presented today who were
online submitter but actually came
forward with some
fair thoughts then there'll be a
separate
appendix to that report prepared by a
communications manager doing the
analysis
of the online feedback showing what the
percentage weightings
is of each of those options that were
put to the people
and one or two other attachments too so
you'll have a
full dossier of information
to guide you
we won't be making specific
recommendations
we may hint that you might want to think
about something
but ultimately it'll be your call we
just hope to give you a platform so that
you can
have an informed debate and come up with
some decisions
thank you uh doug did you have a
question
not a question you worship but i've just
had a um
text or an email from ivonne bannerman
who was
one of the submitters today from the
we've just been awarded 417
000 from the lotto heritage fund
excellent
so um that will bring the shortfall at
this stage down to 236 000.
okay that's great so that's a real win
so yeah yeah that's a bonus for the day
it's a real bonus for dan
just one question will the submitters
that haven't made it today will they get
the opportunity
to submit again or that'll be no that's
the opportunity is today
is today yeah thank you
okay um if there's no further questions
nothing else you've got steve
know your worship i think uh just to let
you know the process so that
next wednesday there'll be deliberative
meeting
where you'll be invited to make
decisions on the issues put forward by
submitters
and one thing i should have also added
to that what staff won't be doing is if
if the submitters are predominantly
political in nature in terms of their
views
we we won't have any input into that
following that there will be
an audit process so the decisions you
make on 9th of june
then have to if there's any changes
required to financial forecasts
and budgets they have to be made and
then
it's put through audit and cleared is
being fit for purpose
and then the council will meet by the
end of june to hopefully adopt the ltp
so the audit process is quite an onerous
task
okay um nothing else counselors have if
not then
like i just thank you for your
attendance today thank you for the
contribution you've made the questions
you've raised
um and also say thank you to the
submitters for those that have
come and spent the day listening and and
also
sharing your thoughts everything is as
valuable as we
decide what the next 10 years should
look like for this particular community
so with that in mind i'll declare the
meeting closed and thank you for your
attendance